ارجع الرجوع هيكون احسن بكتير قوي ان انت
تقضي حياتك طول عمرك بره مش مش البطولات
او الامبين اللي انت هتحب تخشها دي الحاجه
اللي هتخليك مرتاح بعدين لا رجوعك هو اللي
هيريحك وسط اهلك واستناسك
بيبقى نفسه اللي هو يحس بره ويكون فرصته
احسن عن هنا بس هي الفكره كلها في الطريقه
مثلا مش كويسه مش مناسبه يعني هو كان ممكن
يحترف احسن من كده بيفكر في اخده ولما
يرجع ما اظنش مشكله هتبقى كبيره ممكن يقدر
يحلها تاني ويطلع بطريقه تانيه مشرفه
تشتغل في بلد مصر
عشان دي بلدنا المفروض كلنا واحد هنا
وبنحبها
وكلنا برده في نفس الوقت بنقوم بيها
فالرساله المفروض تتوجه للشخص الاصلي اللي
مش شايف
ان نتساءل ما هي القصه من وجهه نظركم
كاتحاد مصري للمصارعه ما الذي حدث
اني البغدوده من الولاد المميزه جدا ولد
مؤدب وعرض محترم كان موهبه يعني كان موهبه
متطلع لها انها تبقى موهبه معنا كبيره ان
شاء الله في المستقبل احنا الفتره اللي
فاتت ديت يمكن حصل تعديل كتير قوي بالنسبه
للعيب المنتخب كلها بدانا نحط مرتبات
وبدانا نعمل لهم
معسكرات واعداد كويس قوي واضح من افضل
الفترات اللي فاتت ديت بس هو حصل لبس في
موضوع طبعا والده ان الفلوس اللي خدها
واتخصم منه الكلام ده كله طبعا
عندنا
انه الحديث عن انه
راتب سته اشهر يبلغ 18,000 جنيه
خصموا منه 14,000 يعني ايه الالفين دول
اللي ولا ولا 4000 بقولوا يعني لا لا هو
اقول لحضرتك على حاجه احنا احنا عندنا
الفئات اللاعبين في الفئه الاولى 8000
جنيه الفئه الثانيه
باخدوده كان من الفئه الثانيه لانه ما
كانش لحد وقتنا هذا حصل على ميداليه ذهبيه
للكبار في افريقيا والفئه الاولى بالنسبه
لنا هم ابطال افريقيا للكبار
لما احنا كنا طبعا مدينا وعد انه بعد
البطوله دي ان شاء الله الكل هيجيب اول
افريقيا يتحط فيها الاولى طبعا الولد كان
في حاجه اسمها رسوم التقاعد اللي هو كان
منتقل من من دي من الهيئه لهيئه تانيه دي
لها رسوم انتقال الرسوم كانت مقدره بحوالي
12,000 جنيه بالنسبه طبعا احنا كسبت دي
احنا مش مش يعني مش هنخليك تدفع المبلغ
دوت احنا هنديك المستحقات ماليه ومن اول
مستحقات ماليه نبقى نخصمها منك يبقى انت
كده ما دفعتش المفروض ان الفلوس دي بتدفع
قبل الانتقاله بس احنا الولد حوالينا نعمل
معاه اكسبت كويس شويه ان احنا نعمله ده
عشان ما يدفعش من جيبه طبعا الولد لما جه
اول مستحقات ماليه كان اول ست شهور ليه ب
18,000 جنيه طبعا خصم منه الضرائب العاديه
خالص اللي بتخصمها الدوله اللي هي ال 10%
كسب عمل و3% ضريبه ودمغه حاجه زي كده يعني
قوانين رولز معينه اتخصم منه بقى النسبه
بتاعه الانتقالات بتاعته اللي هو كان
المفروض يسددها واحنا ما دخلناش يسددها في
بدايه الانتقالات يعني عملنا له تاجيل
ليها شويه هو ده كل المفروض انه كان هيرجع
كان هيرجع من بطوله افريقيا ديت اتحرقت
الفئه الاولى بتاعنا وكان ياخد مرتبه وكان
ليه ست شهور كمان هياخدهم الف جنيه كاملين
بدون اي استقطاعات او خصومات
[موسيقى]